[Music]
isabella monroe just started a new job
working as a development coordinator at
west group properties in vancouver
and she loves it i just honestly
couldn't be happier where i am she's
busy and not looking for a new job but
she keeps getting contacted with other
offers everywhere is hiring right now
everybody is very desperate for people
and i often get linkedin messages which
is a big change for her from just a
couple of years ago to be honest before
the pandemic i was just feeling lucky to
have a job a labor shortage due to
declining birth rates and an aging
population is creating a major shift in
the canadian job market there's now a
war for talent with companies battling
to attract workers in all industries
from hospitality to construction to
banking i think we're at an
unprecedented time where the power
balance between employers and employees
has shifted job postings in canada
overall are up 60 from pre-pandemic so
if you look at data from canada there's
about a million job openings as of right
now there's in fact just about as many
job openings as there are people looking
for jobs
in order to attract candidates companies
need to know what matters to people like
isabella
is that good to john hi come on in and
what it's going to take to win them over
i think right now options are everything
and especially with everybody hiring
right now it's it's really important to
me
but what exactly are the right options
to offer is it higher pay we're happy
better benefits or something else
entirely for isabella it's culture
personally for work it's never been a
clocking clock out kind of job but even
more so now i'm i want a community and i
want a good culture in the company that
i work for that it's not just work it's
outside of work as well
the exposure will be in all units
stephen dollywall works in sales they've
been in business for about 70 years a
year ago when he was looking for a job
he applied for positions and got no
response the market was so competitive
at the time with many people looking for
a job but not that many openings i was
really tough to to find the right fit he
ended up landing a job as a sales
associate seven months ago at the same
company as isabella two beds one basket
started
eight hundred thousand he was looking
for a good work life balance and found
it here we have set hours and we aren't
expected to be available during outside
of our work hours which normally in the
real estate industry are kind of
available all the time so in that sense
you know you really get a chance to step
back from work enjoy the rest of your
life now with the demand for workers
he's being contacted by those employers
who didn't respond to his job
applications a year ago recently i've
had some of those same positions i
applied for now reach out to me
to see if i was still interested in
pursuing that opportunity
alicia shikoloni is the vice president
of people and culture for west group i
think
good talent has their pick in terms of
their employer and we are well aware of
that
to be competitive the company offers
perks like catered lunches gym
memberships and paid volunteer days
employees can leave together and go work
out at a local gym and that's paid for
by west group and we also offer
discounts at local gyms and personal
training and if employees complete 20
workouts they get a free day off
wash dryers here full size
and they have an open door policy for
employees to engage directly with upper
management which means a lot to steven i
feel just as valued as some of our
executives it feels like we're all
pulling in the right direction at the
same time and each of us have our own
part to do
to accomplish our greater goal brian
cropp is chief of research at gartner's
hr practice based out of arlington
virginia he's been researching the shift
in hiring and employment we survey about
a million people or so per year
we download every job description that's
posted online and then analyze that to
understand what employers are looking
for within the labor market what can you
tell me about what people are looking
for when it comes to their work
now versus pre-pandemic first kind of
the most obvious one is that employees
now
expect flexibility that by far and away
is the biggest change now what a lot of
employers think it means is that
flexibility is really just about place
do i work from an office or do i work
from home but from an employee
perspective flexibility is not just
about place but it's also about when i
work can i start working earlier in the
day take a two or three hour break
during the middle of the day because
that meets my needs working from home or
hybrid work was barely on the radar for
many companies pre-pandemic now it's
something the majority of people want
and for some flexibility is more
important than pay
james spearing is the director of talent
acquisition for scotiabank in toronto
and he's currently looking to fill
hundreds of positions
in terms of the things that employees
are looking for does that jive with your
experience we found that
flexibility is super important
very critical and also compensation
depending on the area of course that's
always critical um because that's sort
of you know our financial value but the
concepts around flexibility of work and
culture are two of the most important
employee value propositions for any
talent segment and that's globally it
will take us years to really figure out
how to run a workforce with remote
employees and hybrid employees brian's
research shows the flexibility to work
from home also means employers have to
rethink their perceptions of their
workforce even though all the
performance and productivity data
indicate that an employee is working
remote is just as productive if not more
so compared to employee comes into the
office but managers disagree with that
fact about two-thirds of managers say
they're more likely to promote an
employee comes into the office and more
likely to give an employee who comes
into the office a higher rate
and that would impact specific groups
employers are trying to attract women
are more likely to work remote or hyper
than men
if we do nothing we will have
discrimination against women in a remote
and hybrid world we see a similar trend
with people of color that they're more
likely to want to work remote or hybrid
than other employees and if we do
nothing there we'll have less diverse
leadership pipelines we'll have a less
diverse organization and that will
directly translate to lower performing
organizations that are there in order to
attract a diverse group of candidates
companies are modernizing where and how
they find new people scotiabank has
opened satellite offices in vancouver
and ottawa and it's removed resumes as a
requirement
starting in the fall of 2020 actually we
went resume less for our campus and
early talent entry points across the
bank in canada we realized that what
we're looking for actually at the campus
or early talent level is skills and
traits that will set people up for the
future and we wanted to make sure that
we could look at talent in a different
way they're using a new approach with
the help of recruitment company plum it
offers a 25-minute survey for potential
candidates caitlin mcgregor is the ceo
of the waterloo-based company if you
look at the data that's in resumes
it's full of systemic barriers and
biases that dictate access to education
access to even internships or how fast
somebody's progressed in their career
you can line up 100 people and say okay
these people tomorrow would be eligible
they could do the job but it won't tell
you who out of those hundred people will
actually perform well be a top performer
enjoy the work
however a job that's a good fit is only
part of the solution employees also need
to feel appreciated respected and
understood i think that was actually one
of the most important things for me when
i was looking for a new job is that
having an employer who actually
recognizes my hard work i'm really happy
to put in the hours but i would like to
be recognized one of the biggest things
that we've learned throughout the
pandemic is that we don't have workers
working for us we have human beings that
have real lives real concerns real
families real issues that are impacting
them and the best organizations realize
that if you treat your employees like
people not like workers not only do you
get higher performing employees who are
more likely to stay it's just also the
right thing to do because it creates
better lives for those employees it was
very one way the question that remains
is the shift to accommodate workers in
ways like hybrid work something that
will stick around
i think this is a shift that's permanent
not temporary and the world that we're
going into will be hybrid and remote for
the as long as the eye can see at this
point based on every expectation every
productivity measure every finance
measure every technology measure
this appears to be the world that we're
going to be in for the foreseeable
future brian believes the support
workers are getting now will directly
translate into more successful
businesses a win for the employers and a
win for employees it's great to feel in
demand and have a lot of control over
where i can go with my career and to be
very selective with what i'm looking for
and to find the best opportunity for
myself i want to be doing something that
i love and i want to come to work
excited and happy to see my colleagues
and i totally get that here